how's it going guys
matt here from code tegan tutorials i
just wanted to give a quick
update as uh i don't have any main
productions going on right now but i
wanted to
get to give you guys something to let
you know where i'm at and all and that
sort of thing
um so i did i made a post
a little social community posts recently
that is simply the question
i'm not saying anything assuming
anything or pushing any political
direction just
asking the question is using ai
to trade stocks or crypto unethical
yes or no or depend sleep comment the
majority of people
have said no it's not unethical uh 15
did say yes that's a is that a one in
is that a one and five when it's one six
somewhere around there
i don't know that's not perfectly
accurate percent but
we'll say one and six one in six people
said yeah that's unethical that's not
cool man
and but the majority of people are like
oh do it
do it man do what you got to do to make
that
do narrow hack the system but which
to me you know ethics are a tricky bunch
because if you follow ethics perfectly
well
look it's really not my place to talk
about ethics anymore
sure i've studied a lot and had my own
opinions but i don't i don't want to get
into it anymore
just it's really interesting to see that
most people are just cool with it
honestly i'm not i don't think it's cool
i think it sucks
okay i'm gonna leave it at that all
right so what i really wanted to do here
was read and then comment
on the software gore video i did a while
ago
that i think is really important it's
really long so
um wait a minute what am i doing here
let's back it up
go to comments okay and we're just going
to look at
uh
this comment i want to read it it's
really important squigglyp shout out
very nice
very nice comment appreciate you taking
the time to write it out i think it's
pretty important
and a lot of things that were well said
so
it's very long as you can see so i'm
going to paraphrase some of it
but there's some important things that i
just want to read and talk about
all right so here we go and to quote
this isn't me talking
i'm just going to read this i do agree
with the idea that there
are now more new devs who are just
ignorant to a lot of things they need to
know and thus make more mistakes but i
feel like there's
more going on than that well there's a
lot of information out there in the wild
i think there's only a small amount of
it it's actually good and true
the fact that the internet is a place
where anyone can just
up and decide to post whatever
information code ideas etc whether it be
true or correct
is a major issue that needs to be
addressed
boss i don't know if i would consider
this a main period issue but i see what
he's getting at
and the point here yeah it's uh
anybody can just say anything but the
counter to that
is that it's heavily vetted there's also
anybody can can say hey this is wrong
yeah
so yeah it's easier to find
misinformation
but usually it gets corrected but not
always so it's it's a tricky thing
you got to be careful definitely got to
be careful about what information you're
following um
and i might get to that a little further
uh later in this video because i have
some examples where
this is this is supported
what he just said here is supported all
right we have the exact opposite
problem as the old timers here back 30
or 40 years ago there were fewer people
out there making stuff and smaller
numbers meant you had a limited quantity
of code and information out the while it
was hard to find at all
which makes sense because you know 30 40
years ago
the internet wasn't going wild it was
only specific boards and stuff
i think he talked about that somewhere
here what was out there was generally
spread through news groups and bbs
systems and was heavily vetted built
upon
by people who were very skilled access
was limited
you had to give a to get access to even
be interested in getting access
you have asked a question it would be
answered in a day or two or sometimes
longer by people who had to think about
it had time to think about the issue and
write up a lengthy explanation
and that that's something really
interesting that i hadn't really
considered before i mean i guess it's
obvious when you think about it
but yeah not only the super technical
those that were ready to be in it had
access to these boards and internet you
just
you know nowadays anybody can just
open their phone or web browser and go
to
whatever form stack overflow twitter
facebook whatever it is and just like
look at stuff and post stuff but back in
the day you had to actually
know how to get on these boards
these bbs systems and it wasn't exactly
easy to just build your own computer
back then it's super easy now you can
just follow a guide
all right let's continue today you have
a situation where you can ask
a question on reddit or stack overflow
or whatever and get a dozen answers from
a dozen people in five minutes
yup and those people may or may not know
what the heck they're talking about
these systems incentivize people to
blurt out whatever simple
answer jumps out to the front of their
minds first by awarding points and being
able to win
the answer whatever stack overflow
i mean the first is better than being
right
i don't know if i fully agree with this
but i see the point um
yeah because uh like i was saying
earlier
these are pretty heavily vetted and if
someone says something wrong usually
there's some other person that jumps in
and says hey no that part's wrong or
something
but that doesn't always happen sometimes
people have no idea and they'll just be
like oh that one's the most popular
let's go with that and it's wrong
so that's kind of what he's saying here
i think
but yeah it is i feel like it is
countered by
there often is someone good out there
that
that will correct it or at least try
but i think uh hmm man i hate to bring
up references to old videos where
there's some obscure part where i did
one thing i
even i can't find it anymore but in one
of my videos at one point i did observe
that basically this same thing that
um which would it might have been
oh geez i it might have been the uh vgfx
video or something
there was there was a whole length of
of comments about some issue and i
couldn't find the right answer even the
most popular answer didn't seem to be
right but there was some answer
way at the bottom of some guy that got
zero votes
zero likes he got nothing he posted a
pretty lengthy
basically the most correct answer i
could find
and he basically got totally no
recognition for it
it was either my bgfx video or i don't
know it was one of those
one of those more tricky ones but yeah
so i
i have personally seen this happen
although it's rare most of the time i
feel like it gets corrected but there
are times where it's like the person who
finally took the time to do it right
gets just no recognition
it stinks for them because they're
probably looking at like
wow i took all his time i researched i
put this together
i posted the technically correct answer
and then
people are still just up voting the
wrong one and just not even realizing
that the [ __ ]
yeah it's it's a frustrating thing as
someone who takes the time
and it's it's it's interesting so all
right let's continue
there are a lot of problems and what is
needed is a highly curated place where
people can exchange information and
roommate and actually talk about and
discuss
ideas and solve problems not just chit
chat or blurred out whatever it's in
their head right now
and i think that's what stack overflow
tried to be
and they're okay but i can barely use
stack overflow anymore
it's stack overflow this is a hot take
hot take incoming
this is probably wrong a lot of people
probably gonna disagree with it but this
this is my opinion and my hot take on
stack overflow
as of today
i used to think stack overflow was
really good i used to be able
to google questions about
things when i was basically a noob and
didn't know what i was doing really
and get pretty decent answers but that
doesn't work anymore
i can almost never find the answer i'm
looking for on stack overflow now
because well i think
i kind of know most of the basics and
stack overflow
people only seem to answer with the
basics there's never
or never is not right but there's rarely
like elaborate proper answers it's
usually just
here's a chunk of code to do what you're
trying to do now move on with your life
no more answers please you know it's
that sort of thing
so stack overflow stopped stopped being
useful to me
about a year or two ago and
it was you know it's still somewhat
useful occasionally i find stuff on
there but like ninety percent of the
time
yeah i'm gonna say ninety percent of the
time when i have a problem
i just have to dig in and figure it out
myself there's no answer on the internet
for it
and if if there is it's buried
and there's no easy way to find it so
it suddenly became more about
getting really technical looking at the
fine details and finding my own answer
that's that's how i have to solve all my
coding problems these days
there there are no guides there are no
guides for this
advanced stuff for advanced engineering
you just have to understand the
mechanics behind it all the logic behind
it and
can come up with your thing and if you
try to explain that elaborate
complicated thing to someone
a very very small percentage of people
actually understand it and if you post
that sort of answer
on say stack overflow as we're using as
the example here
it will get down voted or washed away or
people will berate you
because they don't understand it and
they want the simple answer and yeah
it's it's a problem
and it basically leads to more software
gore
okay end hot take that's that's the end
of my hot take
i don't know i'm kind of curious what
other people think about that
or if they have the same experience um
you know from a
newbie perspective or from a pretty
advanced perspective like
how are people actually seeing stack
overload sites like stack overflow these
days because
that's been my experience right there
all right let's continue there are a lot
of problems and what is neat is the
highly curated okay we already
we already said that okay um next one
squiggly p just drop in
bars all right i'm not that strong of a
programmer though
in my 40s mostly resigned to being more
of a hobby for me okay
cool see this is this is good
people need to be honest with where
they're at there's a lot of people that
just
think they're bigger than bigger than
they are and some people probably think
that about me and that's fine i don't
really have any
well i don't know it's it's really hard
to analyze yourself in this sort of
thing but i feel like i don't really
have
that many illusions about my ability i
know i'm not a perfect programmer
i honestly still consider myself kind of
a noob
but uh and i don't know if i'll ever
grow out of that
you know when you're programming
something that's difficult and requires
a lot of complex solutions on a lot of
different
parts interconnecting you always feel
like a new because there's so much going
on it's it's literally impossible unless
you have like a
5 million iq exaggerated but
to like think of all these pieces at
once and keep it all in mind at once so
it's it programming isn't easy uh it's
made to look easy
it's often broken down to be easy for
like one piece at a time
but when you tie it all together it is
it is a lot
and it's pretty complicated so
there are very few strong programmers
out there i i don't think they exist
even like i don't know i
without dropping names i'll say i've had
interviews and gotten jobs for the
people interviewing me
i thought were going to be like super
good programmers but when it came down
to it
even when i was just like you know water
cooler talk
talking about code and whatever i would
often find that i knew a lot that they
didn't
and they've been coding for many years
longer than me and that sort of thing
that became very
a very common thing that kind of
surprised me when i started to get to
the industry is
really like just me
knowing personally that i'm i'm kind of
a noob you know i
kind of had that thing like i got a lot
to learn i'm going to listen to people
i'm going to read a lot
i'm going to try a lot i'm going to try
different things and then getting into
actual jobs and finding out that
these veterans don't really know much
more than i do they know a lot of
technical stuff and there's a lot to
learn from them
there's also a lot of stuff that i
realize that they don't and that sort of
thing
so it's just really interesting
it's it's it's not as simple as it all
seems you can't just say
i have this many years experience thus
i'm better it doesn't work that way we
all have different aptitudes some of us
have incredibly logical minds some of us
have more creative minds and that sort
of thing there's no
there's no year amount that says you're
a good programmer
i have more examples of that but i'll
just leave it at that for now because i
i think that's an important takeaway
okay let's continue
i think a good chunk of the reason why
it's taken me so long to feel like i
have a decent grasp of what i'm doing
and it's a tenuous grasp at best is that
hey there's not enough time in my day to
work on things but more importantly it's
impossible to know as an amateur
programmer who's blowing smoke
up your donkey versus who's got the
goods
i've learned and unlearned a lot of
stuff people who i later discovered
had learned some trick or some quick
easy way to do something
and then decided to teach it like it was
the way to do things
i can relate and maybe i'm guilty of
teaching some things that way so
interesting and uh yeah can definitely
relate
exchange or information has resulted in
a much
higher signal noise ratio
and let a lot of people to only have a
surface level understanding of things
because there's a serious lack of
content with any real
depth or breadth to it okay
now i want to say something about this
that i think is interesting
i think there's actually quite a bit of
content that has depth and breadth to it
especially when you look at a lot of the
advanced computer science lectures on
youtube and stuff
the thing is they are really boring and
nearly impossible to sit through
i've tried i've tried a lot i've tried
like
you know if you watch something
entertaining you're like
wide-eyed paying attention to every
moment but when you listen
when you listen to something boring you
might be able to tune in for a few
minutes and then your mind just is like
oh
going other places doing other things
and before you know it you're asleep or
something
so that's personally what happens to me
when i'm trying to watch something
that's highly involved
and has a lot of details is i have to
watch it in like 10 minute chunks
because
i literally fall asleep and i don't know
what to do about that it's like super
interesting stuff to me
and i want to keep going but my brain is
doing its own thing it's like hey this
is a great time to snooze off
no it's not come on we need this you
know so
i i think there's content out there i
just think it's really boring so that's
kind of one of the things i'm trying to
do with this channel
uh code second tutorials that i'm trying
to make
and i might not always succeed in every
video some of my videos are probably
really boring and make you fall asleep
sorry you know you can always let me
know try to do better
and i am what's trying to do better but
i'm trying to make entertaining content
that has
some of this depth and breadth and it's
an ongoing process
it's it's rather difficult to do
correctly and it takes a lot of time and
a lot of
analysis and revisions and sometimes it
just takes a lot of experience like i
have to
fail a bunch before i finally get it
right and it's tricky to know which ones
to post sometimes
sometimes i'll post something and
realize oh it's so wrong
and i'll have to i'll think about taking
it down but then so many
it's bringing a lot of people to the
channel so i have to make the decision
about
whether i take it down because it's got
some wrong stuff in it or whether i just
leave it up because people seem to like
it and
it brings people to the channel it's
it's
i i don't know what to do about it
sometimes all right let's continue
you get a thin layer of basic knowledge
and copy pasta auto complete your way to
the solution
to a solution i know this is true
because it was absolutely true for me
and still isn't a lot of regards
learning the program has been the most
frustrating things i've ever done
because i learned something only to find
out i was wrong or not really correct
or really only useful in situation x it
wasn't complete
yet been there
i think this is hard to say eloquently
or in the right words but basically it
comes down to
understanding the data i think because
when you find some solution for
something it's often manipulating some
data and if you really understand how
the data is organized and how you want
it to be or whatever you want to change
with it
then you can apply the proper we'll say
algorithm
or function or whatever it is to it but
you know you can you can google the
problem
you can say i have this i want to do
this and you'll find answers and maybe
they're correct maybe they're not
and maybe you don't know you don't know
how to analyze it so that's where a
problem arises because then
later there's a bug in your program and
you don't understand why it's a bug
because you never quite understood the
solution to begin with and then you're
just in a rabbit hole of
or or i don't know we'll say a quicksand
pit of you can't solve it
because there's unknown and yeah
that's it's really complicated to say
you know say what i'm trying to say
there but
you probably get the point all right my
own ideas
this is this is long all right we're
we're getting to the final stretch
let's check out squigglyp's own ideas
very insightful comments so far
all right simplify the process totally
agree yes i've been using c for the last
few years it's small it's easy to
understand
doesn't require some massive collection
of build tools to get it to run
wait i don't know if i would call c
small
and easy to understand but
yeah i i don't you might you might be
smarter than you think you are
squiggly sweetly be because most people
don't consider a c
small and easy to understand most people
find it to be really complicated
i've learned more in the last few years
than i did in the last decade with c
plus python game engines etc very
interesting
to stop incentivizing bad or dumbed down
to rushed information through
gamification of information exchange
platforms instead
incentivize the quality of the actual
content being shared
okay yeah great social media platforms
are a terrible place to find good
information
as they do the worst thing they can do
to ensure quality content
there's some good info out there but
less than one percent of the content
i don't know if i'd agree with those
percents but the point is there the
point is made yeah
facebook is a terrible place to find
information i i've joined some coding
groups and some
see post plus groups and stuff like that
on on facebook
and yeah totally useless information
basically
the only things that get uploaded are
people's memes and
any kind of real stuff is completely
ignored because it's too boring or
something so
yeah social media isn't really a place
to hardly share this there's maybe some
things i don't know about on social
media where it's actually good
it's not like i've seen them all i think
the information out there i'm guessing
it's higher than one percent of good
information though
maybe it's more like fifteen twenty one
percent's a very very small percent
all right three i genuinely think we
need a new beginner language
i myself learned the basics of
programming with basic when i was in
grade school
it was like seven or eight nice i do not
think i would have gotten
c or i would have gotten python i see
people suggest python or other similar
easy languages for children all the time
i think it's a horrible horrible mistake
why on earth would anyone think that
introducing a new programmer
to concepts like oop and inheritance
and crap like that would be a good idea
it blows my mind like teaching their kid
one two threes and abc's and then just
giving them an algebra problem to solve
you know what these mean right it's just
letters numbers also scratch is okay
language that gets suggested but basic
was being used to write commercial
software at the time scratch is not a
language that can grow with the user
you can do advanced stuff with basic any
training wheels
language should be able to teach concept
should be able to teach concepts of
memory management
data structures etc when the time comes
not immediately necessary when starting
out but accessible when you're ready for
it
cool just random thoughts bottom line in
my opinion except the saturation
information and hugely increased demand
for new programmers each
equals a recipe for tech disaster
there's also a huge demand to just
pump out barely trained worker bees with
crash course type boot camps
that magnifies the issue further
excellent excellent comment and
yeah i think you can probably tell if
you watch the video that that's
basically
very close to a lot of the same points
i'm making i don't go into as many fine
details about languages and stuff
but a very valuable comment that i think
a lot of people can get a lot from
i don't 100 agree with it but i agree
with a
giant portion of it i think he's right
so
thanks for the comments quickly best of
luck to you out there
and uh i don't know to the rest of you
out there just you know
keep coding you guys keep working on
stuff i i wish i had the perfect advice
to fix
all this stuff but i i don't and i don't
know if i ever will but i'm gonna keep
trying i'm gonna
you know that's that's basically the
whole point of this channel is to try to
simplify stuff
correctly and that's actually really
quite difficult to do and it's going to
take some trial and error as i'm sure
any
long time followers have seen but
uh you know
moving forward we're just always moving
forward alright appreciate
you guys watching tuning in i'll see you
in the next video
matt out peace